this is the Oasis well I read the ready
player one
I was completely wild by it I suddenly
saw a future and it wasn't that far away
from what I think is going to happen
it's a place with the limits of reality
are your own imagination I could not
have written ready player 1 if I had not
grown up on a steady diet of Steven
Spielberg movies everybody I think who
dreams of making movies dreams of
getting to work with him the first
person to find the egg will inherit half
a trillion dollars and total control of
the Oasis itself
Maurice book was visionary and it needed
a visionary filmmaker so who better than
Steven Spielberg to tell this story hold
on to something
there was anybody who you were going to
entrust to bring the ready player one to
the screen in a way that has tremendous
integrity it would be Steven Spielberg
everyone is just so excited to be a part
of a massive film like this and a steal
at the helm it's been a dream come true
perfect really good cut print that what
nice you're talking to all of you now
because her futures being threatened by
people who will stop at nothing to win
this contest
Steven is very engaging with us he loves
actors and he's willing to try different
things and feel at the scene but really
he knows exactly what he wants I just
figured it out what else second clue I
know what it means
Steven we'll think of things on the spot
he'll just show it from behind gun right
well let me say this do that and it's
just it works a game decides our fate
the only question is how far we wanted
to go to winner he's incredibly focused
on performance the precision that he is
able to give his actors and also once in
his actors is phenomenal
the special effects are gonna be
groundbreaking unlike anything anybody's
ever seen before
and I asked Adam Stockhausen production
designer to design the future right at
the very beginning Steven got together
with us and talked about this world that
split into two halves so we're creating
the virtual world the Oasis but then
we're also creating the real world and
weeds community in the stacks probably
the most iconic image from the book and
now it's a reality and I could just
imagine the stacks and how it would
function but he's made it into a real
working city
I just wonder this movie to be a story
about characters who meet in the Oasis
and they all become best friends and at
the same time I wanted it to be a very
streamlined adventure by implausible at
the high five the name of Artemis in the
name of H in the name of Dido and show
compass apos
[Music]
[Music]